- [Commander] Is that
dude just standing there
between the trees good or bad?
- Hey, I'm right by the mule.
- Where are you in relation
to the burning car?
- [Christian] What we
do here is unorthodox.
We teach the art and the
science of leadership.
- [Commander] Incoming, incoming.
- Both eyes are open.
Now we're gonna go.
- My name is Christian.
I'm a former Marine,
and I am on an undisclosed military base.
We conduct multi-day,
pseudo-military operations,
with corporate executives and veterans,
so that when we conclude these missions,
the executives say, “Hey,
we need to hire a lot more
of these men and women.”
We're gonna help organizations move better
by doing something that's
also considered a social good.
- Right now, there's over
250,000 service members
that transition out of
the service every year.
My goal is to make sure
that no veteran goes
through the same situations
that I had to go through.
- Casey went from the
pinnacle of athleticism
to someone who was carted
out of a dusty battlefield
in Afghanistan, paralyzed.
When he was recovering,
he was told he was never gonna walk again.
And he said, Well, no.
And he persisted.
After two years, he actually
walked out of the hospital.
He was discharged just a
number of months later,
and Casey, this war hero,
finds himself living out
of his car for a while.
- I had just gotten out.
I was one of those typical veterans,
I was like, you know what, I got this.
I'm gonna go out there; I have
all of these marketable skills,
everybody's gonna wanna hire me.
I was wrong.
- [Christian] When our
veterans transition,
out of the military, they
have to find the uniform
that they're gonna wear
in their future career.
- [Casey] My closet used to
be all camouflage uniforms.
Now, I'm talking about pocket squares,
and ties, and cuff links,
but the thing is,
is I love when I put on a suit.
It makes me feel empowered,
and gives me a sense of
belonging with my peers now.
I knew that I can get from
where I was in the military,
I just needed the opportunity.
Christian saw that within me.
- You know, this is the,
our last night together,
and you've learned a lot.
- Really more than anything,
you learn about people,
and you learn about relationships,
and how important that is.
- What always comes to
my mind is how I live a,
charmed life.
Meeting you, dude, and your story, just,
it just cuts to the bone.
- What you guys are
doing for these veterans
on a daily basis,
you guys are my heroes.
We are gonna change the
way that America looks
at hiring veterans,
hiring a veteran as good business.
- Life is simply bettered
if we're in service
to something bigger than ourselves.
What we do here is our
attempt to dent the universe.
We're unsure whether
we'll dent the universe,
but we're gonna swing like hell at it.
(ambient tone)